so the first point is that bring us back
to naturalism there is a view out there
not in this room that if materialism is
true then life has no meaning that's to
put it in the starkest terms I mean so
we know despite this is especially in
the West 19th century sort of reaction
to many people say so Max Weber talks
about the disenchantment of the world
and that the the evolution besides sort
of environmental problems and political
problems in Europe the results of this
idea that the movement from there just
being not serviced in Chapter now that's
interesting because there's magic and
mystery to nature and we're discovering
what it is but then with the growth of
the Geist is vishton Chaston right the
the spirit sciences that's now getting
spooky because you're starting to sort
of explain human behavior with the same
principles and this so this familiar
refrain that we hear that we get in in
Weber and and other people we see the
same kind of it's kind of vertigo it's a
kind of a existential anxiety to the
idea that we humans might be and this is
in the wake of Darwin and other people
right that we might be 100 percent
animal as we all in this room think and
that our fate is that of other mammals
and of course clearly just given I don't
think that there's anything intrinsic to
the reaction of thinking that that's
intrinsically depressing but obviously
in terms of an antecedent set of
cultural traditions which say that the
entire meaning of life has to do with
how you fare as it were after you die
and are judged and that you will be
judged largely in terms of the moral
quality of your life so this is one of
the ways of connecting it up we may
still make jokes we naturaliss right
about what happens Alex was telling some
this morning when you get to the pearly
gates and what st. Peter says to you and
things like this I mean so this is a
very familiar way of thinking about
ourselves so so what is the so this is
just but back to what Dan talked about
yesterday
in terms of this is a political kind of
issue but it's also has I think it's a
project that we naturalist have to be
sensitive to that we have to find a way
of speaking and saying things that are
as I put it upbeat and not depressing
about the meaning and significance of a
human life given that we're finite
beings living in a material world we're
finding material beings living in a
material world and when we're done we're
done maybe
actually Frank Jackson's review of my
books was about Madonna he said called
me material boy but so so that's kind of
background and I think that's just as I
say is they sort of a cultural know um
so but now I want to just jump back and
ask this question so we talked about the
fungibility of of moral concepts and the
difficulty of locating them and
grounding them in firm on firm soil
subspace the attorney taught this it
doesn't look like that's going to be
what we're going to be able to do in
morals and I think similar problems will
occur when we tried to give naturalistic
views of meaning but I'm glad Don
brought up his I think excessively
optimistic view about what the game
theoretical approaches could give us but
I now want to take us back 2500 years
and just connect the morals and the
meaning issues so Aristotle says he goes
around Athens or not actually Athens I
think he was going all around Greece I
don't think he was housed in Athens most
of the time but he says I ask people
what they want that they want for its
own sake that they want for nothing else
this is a just a question about
psychology right first pass so a lot of
things they want for instrumental
reasons like they want money because it
buys them stuff and so on and so forth
but what do they want for non
instrumental reasons and he keeps
getting this answer from his compatriots
they want eudaimonia which I put on the
board it's a it means something like EU
means good and Damon means spirit so it
means something like happy spirit and
actually until about 1975 when I was a
graduate student it was translated as
happiness but then people yeah but that
actually changed in around 19
seventy-five John Cooper at Princeton
actually started to say no that's the
wrong word because well he doesn't say
this I say this Aristotle says even if a
person if a person dies and you give the
eulogy at their funeral even if you know
all the facts about them
you can't declare them you Damon that
would be a flourishing person until you
see how the grandchildren turn out now
that's kind of interesting because it
means that whatever that at least the
conception that he saw in his culture
okay of human flourishing was not just
subjective it had to do with in some
sense the the not forever effects that
you leave but some of the effects okay
that's right
sure okay so I think this is important
and interesting I mean he's just he's
reflecting a where Greek culture had
gotten circa 400 BCE in terms of what it
thinks what kind of things are important
if we're making a good human life and so
now the and so the question I just want
to have us reflect on it and I think it
comes up in spades I mean and gets us
into the areas of purpose and design and
maybe emergence even if evolution is
purposeless or non theological there do
you seem to be creatures like us who are
planners and make have desires and make
projections about how we want our life
to go I don't think I don't mean there's
anything like a blueprint sense I just
think we all have senses of what we want
to accomplish sometimes it's only what
we can't want to accomplish next
Thursday sometimes it's what we you know
especially when we're young we want to
finish University we then might want to
go on to some other school we want to
work in certain ways we want to do this
in that margin so Aristotle says there
are very few constraints on what he
notices that people have different views
about what constitutes purpose meaning
and flourishing he says there's only
actually one thing he detects that
everyone says and this might be a
constraint from human nature he says no
one would ever choose to live without
friends
meaning he's doing sort of sociology
just as I just don't find anyone like
that
some people think it's a good idea to go
after the mountaintop for a while some
people actually do think a life of
contemplation is the bomb
some people think life of political
power or reputation all the same
contenders we have now sex drugs rock
and roll they're all contenders he says
I see people like this but they all
agree on one thing that they would never
want to live a life without friends and
this then leads him to to say more
things and and I don't want to go into
what our sauce says but I think what
what I want to ask us to reflect on is
naturalist in this why I say it goes
along with it seems to me and some of
the discussion this morning was like
this there are multiple goods and
they're heterogeneous and they're not
easily unified so just to speak in the
way Stephen was speaking the sort of
normative view that I prefer and if I
had world enough in time I would try to
convince you of is that a good human
life is a life lived at the
intersections of the true the good and
the beautiful all with small letters not
platonic ideals these are just like it's
good to know about what science says
it's good to be around beauty and it's
good to be around morally excellent
people as we define morally excellent
but those things sometimes compete and
there's no algorithms about how to
figure them out now the question is is
there though anything that we can say
that's reasonable about what kind of
things make a good human life good and
here I so I've been pushing the this
idea for a few years what I call you
demonics which I like the word better
than happiness studies or well-being
studies because it's a Greek cipher and
no one knows what it means and Jeffrey
Sachs is trying to push it we were at a
meeting with about before a whole bunch
of measures about human wellbeing were
brought to the UN back in March last
year the idea being so here's the idea
it could there be such a science and
what would look like a science that's
descriptive and normative they would
tell you not only sort of what is
producing various kinds of well-being
but also make give you information that
one could use either individuals or
political groups about what would do
better make
I'll just give there's already stuff
like this going on is the point and it's
among people like us so there's some
work on doing hedonic measures of
well-being these are just seeing how
many units of pleasure you get in a day
you can carry around your pleasure
he domitor like you could carry around a
pedometer on your waist but you have to
press it and some people just look at do
subtractions at the end of a day how
many happy moments do people have
compared to negative moments and this
seems to be a measure of some kind of
state that people like yeah yeah dan
conovan actually does hook up people
with these things sometimes so for
example you know you find not to pick on
the Brit in the room the only one I mean
a Brazilian who has 18 positive
experiences in one day and 16 negative
ones is a plus two they are bad as happy
in some these feed on ik measures as a
Brit who has three positive and one
negative because it's both plus two so
this is just this is like pretty
primitive social science but the point
is and they do find these huge
differences between cultures okay in
terms of but those are those are one
kind of experience but obviously that's
not a measure that captures what most of
at least many of the things that we mean
by flourishing because if we think about
things like you know was Martin did
Martin Luther King jr. flourish or did
Gandhi flourish we don't think about it
we think we want to answer yes they have
a purposeful meaningful lives but it
wasn't cuz of the hedonic units this
comes out and like Dan says if your best
friends are doing just that but there's
a problem there are these then
subjective well-being measures which a
lot of people use you know asking people
what are the most important domains of
your life and how are you faring in
terms of them and then there are these
objective measures so for example you
know Dan condiment will talk about the
you know the flatline that occurs after
people make it's a moving target
whatever it is wait now 100,000 is what
I heard at this meeting across the world
once it was the family of four is at a
hundred thousand okay then there's no
increase in well-being with the more
money you have
there's increase in other things you can
buy stuff obviously or for example if
you ask college kids how important is
making money to you and you divide the
groups in American colleges you get this
about fifty percent will say it's the
most important thing
and about 50% we'll say it's second or
below and it turns out that the ones who
say it's the most important thing you
can make Isis much money to be at the
same level of well-being later on so
what I give this taught when I give a
talk about this stuff to students I say
you should work on yourself to make
yourself not desire money because it
will [ __ ] you up in this particular way
and so that's just a way of I mean I
just use that as an example of where you
can use some information about what how
people get on hedonic treadmill is make
themselves miserable and then you can
make recommendations of that if you want
your life to go this way then it would
be better to and I take that that's
continuous with some of the
recommendations that are being made
about how we conceive of moral knowledge
and how we use practical wisdom but so
the idea here is just to connect up what
I've just been saying is a way of
connecting up both considerations about
how we want to do our lives what will
make our lives good and meaningful ones
by thinking about natural resources
historical resources sociological
psychological economic whatever is there
it's just use all the knowledge that's
out there and but it's natural knowledge
is the point but it's highly fallible it
doesn't grab anything with certainty and
so on
you